les avocats de jacky martens en
négociation avec le bâtonnier une image
marquante hier alors qu'il venait de
quitter tous trois la salle avec fracas
provoquant une suspension de séance un
éclat révélateur d'une stratégie de
défense très offensive principale cible
de leurs reproches la qualité de
l'instruction donc pensons que
différentes pistes qui ont été
importantes n'ont pas été exploitées de
manière suffisamment le pugnace nous
allons débattre des travaux puisque le
procès débute hier l'accusé s'est
exprimé les témoins vont défiler à la
barre notamment les enquêteurs et
naturellement nous aurons des questions
à leur poser des débats rugueux des
confrontations parfois frontale avec
l'avocate générale et la présidente de
la cour d'assises des retards répétés un
ensemble qui pèsent sur l'atmosphère du
procès
c'est pas dans l'intérêt de de tout ce
que les débats se déroulent sur ce ton
la justice ne peut être bien rendu qu'à
partir du moment où les choses sont
abordés de façon sereine pour mes
clients c'est extrêmement difficile
d'assister à cette espèce de joutes
beaucoup d'agitation dans la salle mais
finalement peu de lumière sur les faits
en trois jours d'audience si jacky
martens a clamé son innocence la famille
d'anne sophie girollet restent encore
sans réponse n'est toujours pas fixé sur
sur ce qui s'est passé et on a des
doutes vraiment sûr risque un jour on va
l'être vraiment c'est très douloureux
pour moi personne personnellement en
tant que frère et pour ma famille
familles entières d'autres débats animés
ne manqueront pas dans les prochains
jours il reste encore plus d'une semaine
de procès est le point crucial des
analyses adn impliquant jacky martin n'a
pas encore été abordée